hey everybody it's Kevin Van Ord here
and I just had a chance to check out the
new trailer for The Witcher 3 and I
wanted to sit down with you and take a
look at it and see what we could find
out we take a closer look so nothing new
here at the beginning dead bodies from a
tree guys on horseback including
returning star Geralt of Rivia but what
is this it looks like some strange some
strange beings there this would probably
be the members of the Wild Hunt which is
so the Wild Hunt is essentially a group
of spectres that roamed the skies and
they come every so often to bring new
people into their ranks and there we see
Geralt again but now some more
interesting things start to happen so
there's a really interesting shot coming
right about now and this looks to be who
I'm going to guess is ciri and now we
just have a look at the Emperor just a
moment ago it seems like that is the
emperor of nilfgaard and here we see
ciri and ciri is somewhat of Geralt
adopted daughter in a sense although he
did not adopt her by normal fashion he
was she was actually what we'll call her
8a a gift for removing a curse from her
father and there's a lot of interesting
stuff that's now gonna be wrapped up in
here because it looks as though the Wild
Hunt is coming after ciri who had been
already you know taken by the wild hunt
as well as Geralt love of his life who
would be yennefer and here you see the
havoc that the Wild Hunt can actually
read and you see a figure here I am
going to assume that this is the king of
the wild Punk that we saw just a moment
ago but again here we see Geralt and the
emperor speaking
and I don't know that the emperor has
good things in store for ciri now that
he knows it's definitely her we know
that she's definitely on the run from
the Hunts some beautiful shots here some
typical trailer stuff as well as some
great looks of the the different
monsters that Geralt is gonna be
fighting and again I presume that's the
king of the wild hogs look let's stop
there for just a moment because I want
to point out we've got Geralt obviously
here in the front featuring his his
gorgeous scar and a little bit more wear
and tear on his face and some new facial
hair as well but we've got on one side
Triss Merigold which whom you probably
know if he played obviously know if he
played The Witcher or The Witcher 2 but
on the other side you have a woman clad
in black and white and she is absolutely
yennefer and it should be interesting in
the upcoming game to see how those two
characters Tris any Anna for both of
whom which are Geralt loves in in his
own way it's gonna be interesting to see
how this plays out and to see whether or
not we will get a chance to choose one
over the other but yennefer always wears
black and white and so it's absolutely
certain that that's who that is we see
some of the the trouble that daryl is
gonna find himself in bear under water
nasty thing to fight and here's hoping
that the combat system has been a little
bit more more tightened up some sexy
time a few moments ago there with Geralt
a lot of monsters and here he comes we
see Geralt we see the king of the wild
hunt and we see a release date which is
February 24 2015 and let's not forget
through all this that there is a
prophecy in play it's an
end-of-the-world prophecy the world's
supposedly is going to end in a very
cold chilly manner and leave only elves
behind so gonna be interesting to see
where this game goes if we see the
prophecy fulfilled or not
but obviously I'm excited about The
Witcher 3 and you're probably excited
about The Witcher 3 so make sure to stay
tuned the games but I suspect that we'll
probably have a look at the game at the
upcoming e3 so watch next week and let
us know what you think in the comments
below it's been great having you here
again
I'm Kevin Van Horn and I'll see you next
time